who is man God Adam Warlock will rocket
breathe his last breath and what's with
all the talking animals The Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 trailer is packed with
tiny details that reveal more about the
movie than you might think
toward the end of the trailer the
Guardians are cut off during an escape
by a giant red monster with rows of
teeth it's a blink and you'll miss it
moment but we've actually seen this big
sucker before this is the Obelisk who
the team fought in the opening Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2. remember when baby
Groot danced obliviously around as his
Pals battled the slithery gooey monster
this might let us know where the
Guardians are at in volume 3 as when
they first encountered the Obelisk they
were on the Sovereign Planet but since
this Behemoth is a multi-dimensional
being they really could be anywhere now
however with Adam Warlock showing up in
the trailer they are more than likely
actually on Sovereign with all those
golden Beauties following up on the
ominous post credit scene of volume 2.
since the first Obelisk we saw in the
Guardians franchise was destroyed it
looks like there is definitely more than
one of these guys but what batteries is
he trying to inhale this time
okay so we all knew Adam Warlock would
be in Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 so
this isn't some big Easter egg you might
have missed what's more interesting is
Adam's look and how he's stealing Vision
style the golden Gladiator has a silver
diamond-shaped gem in the middle of his
forehead could this be some kind of new
infinity stone in the comics the high
evolutionary gives Adam Warlock what's
known as the soul gem which is known as
the Soul Stone in the MCU this allows
him to suck the souls out of other
beings eventually warlock realizes there
is a dark side to the soul gem in
Strange Tales vol 1 number 178 in that
story Thanos gets the five other
infinity gems and comes for warlock but
the Mad Titan ends up making somewhat of
a clone of the stone we know we're not
seeing Thanos again so the story and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 will
definitely stray from the comics it
looks like we'll see warlock's more evil
side in the film but he's most often
known as a anti-hero
as the trailer threatens that it's time
for the Guardians to face the music it
seems likely that at least one of our
heroes will meet their end this
foreboding sense of tragedy and
sacrifice is underscored in one of the
trailer's final moments where in Groot
Bellows The Immortal last words of his
father
as he says this he and quill seem to be
surrounded by an army of enemies firing
shots as though they were making their
last stand the last time we heard this
phrase was seconds before Groot perished
in the original Guardians of the Galaxy
several key characters are in obvious
Jeopardy throughout the trailer in one
scene nebula is seen carrying an
unconscious quill in another Gamora
supports a critically wounded Drax
mantis an empath who takes on the
emotions of others is seen wailing in
anguish her emotion appears almost
identical to a moment with quill who at
one point seems to be overseeing a
failing medical procedure the hint here
is a lingering shot of a bloody
instrument followed by his scream with
what may be a breathing apparatus in the
background of all its core players
however rocket seems to be the most
poised to die through ominous tears he
says we'll all fly away together one
last time into the forever that
beautiful sky rocket is also seen bathed
in a white vast Heavenly light in one of
the trailer's quick shots gun may be
gearing up to off most if not all of the
Guardians cast after all the director
proved his willingness to kill his
Darlings in both previous installments
as well as his iteration of The Suicide
Squad after nearly 10 years of playing
these roles the actors may also be ready
to say goodbye
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 will
likely be the last we see of many team
members at least under the care of
writer director James Gunn but a lot of
care is still going into building their
backstories the first trailer seems to
focus a lot on Rocket Raccoon and his
Origins one of the biggest hints of this
is a quick moment where he Embraces the
sentient otter known as Lila in the
comic books she plays a significant role
in Rocket's life often serving as a
teammate and love interest for the
character she's now finally making her
big debut in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as for who will voice the
character that still isn't clear there
were some rumors back in 2019 that she
would be portrayed by none other than
Lady Gaga who previously appeared in a
star is born with Cooper hey
what
I just want to take another look at you
those rumors are unconfirmed at best and
should still be taken with a massive
grain of salt regardless introducing her
character now is a big move for gun and
Company and should add another emotional
layer to Rocket's backstory
for the majority of the trailer the
Guardians wear matching red and blue
leather costumes this look is seemingly
a combination of the group's established
MCU leather-clad uniform and the color
scheme and iconography of their comic
book Revival Peter Quill was brought
into the Modern Marvel Comics Universe
in 2004's Thanos number eight but he
wouldn't get a superhero style costume
until the annihilation Conquest event
three years later he sported a
militaristic redesign from artist Marco
dergevic when the character began
leading a new Guardians of the Galaxy
team in 2008 he and the others were a
slightly altered red and blue version of
durgific's costume this appears to be
the inspiration for their attire and
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. another
eye-catching wardrobe moment involves
the vibrant Technicolor spacesuits worn
by the team for what appears to be an
Extended space walking sequence both
these simple classic astronaut design
and the suit's bright colors had many
fans on Twitter drawing connections to
the popular video game among us whether
or not the game served as a direct
inspiration the visual is undeniably
striking
foreign
[Music]